hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
now what we're looking at are
other components of moral decision
making
so utilitarianism focuses a lot on
consequences
but bentham also talks about three other
very important things intentions
motives and dispositions
so intentions what are our intentions
you know sometimes people will say
things like well
things didn't go according to my
intentions or i had good intentions but
but it backfired yeah
like did you drive any voices
okay that's actually a bit more like
motives
so hold on to that thought yeah it's
what you had like
hope that your action was
exactly it was what you had in mind what
you when we say intent
it means what you're sort of like
projecting out ahead this is going to be
the effect of my action somebody else
had their
hand up yeah i was going to say it's
like what was initially planned
very often intentions and plannings go
hand in hand
and you know with a given action bentham
points out you might intend
part of it but you didn't intend all of
it you know
um you intended
the part that you did but then you
didn't happen to notice that the other
person was coming down the hall at the
same time
so shooting the nerf gun down the hall
whacked somebody in the eye and
put up you know the proverbial eye and
uh now it's a big problem right
you say well i i didn't intend to do
that sort of thing
it just sort of happened that way
in that case the act has consequences
that were unintended right
now people can have intentions to do bad
things
um people come along all the time say
i'm gonna mess you up
if they're saying something like that
they're saying i have the intention of
injuring you right that's what i'm going
to mess you up
usually substituted in another word
that's what it means that's that kind of
intention
isn't it intentions are
for bentham always singular they're
always concrete they're in the situation
so why are you here in this classroom
because you have the intention of
showing up
and why aren't you sleeping right now
you know with your head on the desk
because you have the intention of paying
attention
um and you're in fact doing that it's
leading to an action right
why am i talking about bentham because i
have the intention of
communicating some of bentham's moral
theory to you
in our class session i plan to do that
so planning could be part of it
um if suddenly i spill you know
water on my laptop and i quickly i say
somebody go get get paper towel
i'm operating on an intention i want to
make sure that my laptop doesn't get
destroyed
this is all fairly easy to grasp stuff
right so
you have a lot of experience with having
intentions
and you can have more than one intention
at a time right you can be of a
split mind on something you want to
uh let's say you're invited to two
different places by two different
friends at the same time and you like
equal
you like them equally and you don't want
to let them down
you have the intention of going to both
of them but you can't actually act on
the intention
you're familiar with this sort of stuff
so now motives you talked about
more things that drive us right
motives are something a bit deeper
these are something if intentions are
concrete in the individual circumstances
or the situation
motives are something that you carry
around with you
and they're a bit more lastic they're a
bit more who you are
you know you could you could do
something you could intend some act and
that could be uncharacteristic for you
but your motives are as bentham says the
pains and pleasures that you allow
yourself to be affected by to to go into
your decision making
to determine your choices
in a consistent way so some people have
different motivations
than others some motivations we see as
being good some motivations we see as
being bad
and you know you think about when you
were in english class
and you do book reports or reports about
you know characters and plays you have
to talk about the person's motives
what's driving them that's the question
you ask
so what's a disposition
not a term we use an awful lot but you
could say somebody's got a good
disposition or a bad disposition yeah
um is it what they think the result will
be
no that's the that's again the intention
that's what they're aiming at yeah is it
kind of like their demeanor the way they
conduct themselves
kind of yeah that's that's a good way to
put it
um bentham doesn't use those terms
because he's using a more victorian
language
we don't talk about disposition very
much he is of an indignant disposition
you know characteristically we we say
that person has a good demeanor or a bad
demeanor
uh attitude sometimes we talk in terms
of somebody's a
good attitude or a bad attitude um
you said disposition the way you conduct
yourself ah
yeah so when you talk about the way you
conduct yourself
you're talking about something that's
present not just in one
intention the act consequence one
situation but how you
characteristically conduct yourself
over time how what kind of a person you
are
and these two are going to be
more important for becca in terms of
the nature of the the individual person
where we actually carry out moral
evaluation he says
is in terms of consequences and motives
consequences of generating pleasure
or pain so you know he says over and
over again things like
we want to evaluate here we go
a man's intention can be styled good or
bad with reference either to the
consequences of the acts
or to his motives if it's deemed good or
bad in any sense it must be because it's
deemed to be productive of good or bad
consequences what makes good
consequences good
they produce more pleasures and pain for
more people
what makes bad consequences bad they
produce more pain than pleasure
so if my intention
is to harm you that's a bad
intention because if i actually i'm able
to follow through on it
the consequence is just generating pain
for you
if i happen to get my kicks out of that
that may introduce a little bit of
pleasure
but you experiencing the pain outweighs
the pleasure
if my intention is to
here's a great example so i've got this
you know
knee brace because i tore two ligaments
in my knee this summer and
technically speaking i suppose i could
get a handicap permit
but why don't i have a handicapped
permit partly it's because they don't
cry because i want to
feel like i'm handicapped but also
because
you know who really ought to get to use
those spaces
i'm able to get around i i'm wearing a
knee brace and nowadays
anything can qualify you for a handicap
permit
but i feel kind of bad because you know
i
i could just imagine pulling up to that
parking spot
and getting out with my my knee brace oh
yeah i had to you know crush for a while
that would make
sense and i get out and i you know walk
to the store
walk my 10 yards or whatever it is to
the store
and then i'll see somebody else with an
oxygen tank
and you know in a wheelchair and they
didn't get to park in handicaps
the handicap space because i took it
i'd feel pretty bad if you were in that
sort of situation wouldn't you feel bad
you know maybe you could get a
handicapped permit but you probably
shouldn't use it
why would i feel bad well because i
would be leading
my intention of you know using that that
permit
would be leading to the situation that
would generate more pain than pleasure i
not only feel bad and embarrassed
that person would have to like hoof it a
while
who doesn't really feel like doing that
um now if i was a jerk
you know let me give it a handicap
permit so i can like stick it to the
old people then i'd be taking pleasure
in their pain
but it still probably would not be
enough pleasure to help outweigh their
pain plus you know what if you saw me
let's say you saw this situation let's
make it as as
stark as possible so we've got some 90
year old lady who's in a wheelchair
with an oxygen tank what else should we
give her to make her like super
handicapped um
she got like one of those she's got a
neck brace on too and
uh what else can we add to the picture
yes so even if she gets out of the
wheelchair she's getting in trouble
um let's give her a one eye
pirate patch this is getting a little
frivolous but um
then you see me walking along and let's
say i don't even have the knee brace on
you see me get out of the car and walk
those you know
10 10 yards and now you see this other
lady like circling
around the parking lot finally finding a
spot
and she has to like hobble her way it
takes her five minutes to get across the
blazing hot parking lot
would you be kind of ticked off would
you feel a sense of indignance
look at that guy what a jerk
well that would be feeling pain
would you feel sorry for the old lady
that would also leave you feeling pain
on her part so i would be creating a
situation that would have a greater
balance of pain over pleasure you can
have bad intentions
and you can also have good intentions
you know i
uh help the old lady across the street
good act
she doesn't get hit by a car you know
nobody feels bad everybody feels good
so what about motives how can we
evaluate those
sounds like motives are something
different
that we could uh
evaluate on their own basis and we'll
look at some
ways to do that but really what it comes
down to
certain motives are going to lead
characteristically to outcomes
another way of talking about
consequences is outcomes
outcomes that are more pleasurable
others are going to lead to
outcomes that are more painful here we
go he says
um if any sort of motive can in
consideration of its effects be termed
with proprietary bad one
it can only be with reference to the
balance of all the effects
it may have had of both kinds within a
given period that is of its usual
tendency
so people who like hurting other people
sadists
that that is a motive that's part of the
motive
that bentham would call malevolence
do they tend to produce situations tend
to produce outcomes
that are more painful than pleasurable
for
most of the people involved yeah so
that's a bad motive
what about people who tend to volunteer
their time their energy
for causes that alleviate suffering
generally create more pleasure than pain
even if it means like they're not
hanging out with their friends so their
friends are a little bit ticked
or you know not showing up for a family
event
but they are serving at the soup kitchen
or in the free clinic
or you know we even make perhaps we
could say you know
some political things might be that way
engaging in activism for the greater
good
that would be a good motive in general
what about dispositions well we evaluate
that in the same way too
in terms of consequences does the
disposition
tend to on the whole produce actions
which lead to a greater balance of
pleasure over paint than their good
dispositions do they tend to
lead instead to
balance a pain over pleasure then
they're bad this is pretty
pretty straightforward isn't it so
that's how we
evaluate these sort of character traits
the things that make us
who we are that give us our basic drives
our basic uh patterns of behavior
and motivation now notice he says
something else that's really
interesting about this he's got a lot of
examples in here
when it comes to a lot of different
motives
that is the tendency to be influenced by
some pleasures or pains
we describe them differently in
different situations
sometimes we see them as good sometimes
we see them as bad
he gives you a whole bunch of great
examples
let me just mention a few of these
so for pleasures of of uh
sense he says a very
typically victorian language a boy who
does not want for evictuals steals a
cake out of a pastry cook shop
and eats it in this case his motive will
be universally deemed a bad one you know
ask what it is it may be answered
perhaps licorice
now i've never heard of anyone calling
anybody licorice
in my life but what does that mean the
kid just likes to eat stuff
he likes he likes the taste of things
and he steals a cake
um what's his motive to gratify his
senses
that's a bad motive in this case because
the you know what happens
the shop owner's ticked he's mad because
the cake has been stolen the kid got
some pleasure on eating the cake
but the shop owner is mad and whoever
else wanted to eat that cake is put out
as well
so it's a bad motive a boy buys a cake
out of the pastry quick shot
and eats it in this case his motive can
scarcely be looked upon as good or bad
unless his master be out of humor with
him then perhaps he may call it
licoriceness as before
here we have a sort of neutral thing go
ahead and buy yourself we
let's substitute candy instead of cake
kid goes into a shop
what's a candy you guys like in
particular halloween is coming now
what's what's your favorite candy
lisa's pieces those are pretty good
everybody likes reese's pieces except
anyone with a peanut
allergy probably don't like it then
it kills you but
so a kid goes in the shop right he has a
hankering for reese's pieces
stuffs it in his pocket walks out that's
that was a bad yeah that was a bad move
in general um kid goes and buys it
he's motivated by the same thing wanting
reese's pieces
wanting something sweet to to eat but
now it's an okay moment
what made it good or bad the
consequences that it might take
so the same thing could be good or bad
depending on
the tendency of the consequences he
talks about um
the pleasures of the sexual sense uh in
a neutral sense maybe term sexual desire
um neither good nor bad right and
everybody
has some degree of sexual desire if you
don't then your
your hormone balances are like totally
off and you better get that checked
because that's not normal um
if it leads to he says um
in a bad sense it's spoken under the
name of lascitiousness and a variety of
other names of reprobation
we talk about lust for example and he
says a man ravishes a virgin
in this case the motive is without
scruple term by the name of lust
and so forth and universally looked at
as abandoned so if you're
because of sexual desire you force
yourself on somebody else
bad consequences creating more pain than
pleasure
right so it's a bad motive on the other
hand he says the same man
at another time exercises the rights of
marriage with his wife
in this case the motive is accounted
perhaps a good one or at least
indifferent i think in general in our
society we're a little bit more
uh what would you call it
we recognize that this is a good motive
you know the intimacy that comes
with relationships that sort of thing
um it's the same motive wanting to have
sex
it's the same desire for the same kind
of pleasure
but it's as it goes through this chain
the consequences are different aren't
they and that's what makes it good or
bad
he has just a ton of different examples
like this
we don't necessarily need to look at too
many of them
but let's let's talk about one though
that's particularly important
in our own culture wealth
we do have a desire for wealth did any
of you want to be poor
you already have a desire for that do
you have a desire to to have money
not necessarily be you know stinking
rich uncle scrooge jumping into piles of
coins and dollar bills that wouldn't be
good for you anyway
it hurt like hell to jump into a pile of
coins um can you imagine doing that
that was kind of
but you know we do want well you know
that money is good for stuff
now that desire for wealth that can be a
very strong motive
people kill each other for that sort of
thing at least in you know
movies actually doing real life as well
he says to the pleasures of wealth
corresponds a sort of motive which in a
neutral sense may be termed pecuniary
interest
being interested in you know making
money in a bad sense what do we call
the desire for wealth when we don't like
somebody's desire for wealth what do we
call them he says actress
but do you talk about anyone being
avaricious
great exactly yeah and
generally we look at greed as a bad
motive don't we
somebody's greedy they want more than
their fair share they're always talking
about what they can get out of things
he also talks about covetousness that
would be more for
property or things that other people
have rapacity
luker filthy lucr um
being cheap being stingy those are all
bad ways of talking about that motive of
wanting the pleasure of money
what about in a good sense somebody
desires money
they do in such a way that leads to good
consequences
they do in fact get their hands on money
what do we call that kind of person
do we have good names good ways of
talking about that
frugal they're they're a frugal person
that's usually like having to do with
the not spending too much on things
do we talk about people like finding
good sources of income
a positive way we have the term hustler
to
hustle but that has some negative
connotations yeah
entrepreneurial yeah okay
entrepreneurial
uh as an adjective the entrepreneur
um that's a that's a positive term
usually
yeah drifty thrifty yeah uh that works
i think that one has to do more with
like conserving what you've got
right making everything count do we have
any other terms
frugal frugal yeah we use that one so
you notice the same thing the same
motive can be used
over and over again in positive or
negative ways but depends entirely on
what the consequences